'chief weathercaster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station WCBS is here to show us
the science behind this eruption Lonnie
good morning and good morning to Vlad
good morning everybody
not the earthquakes that Carter just
mentioned are the direct result of the
pressure that builds up when molten rock
travels underground Mount Kilauea has
been at a constant state of eruption
since 1983 and the most recent eruptions
were caused in part by the collapse of a
crater that was filled with lava just a
week ago you can see that the crater is
now empty and what's rising is not steam
that's actually dust from the collapse
of the floor and that crater is more
than ten miles from the leilani estates
it's more than 25 miles from the center
of the volcano so that lava traveled a
great distance and when that floor caved
in that lava went back underground it
traveled all along the east rift zone
right here all the way out to the
Leilani estates and that's that lava
pushed further and further along it
formed cracks in the surface and these
cracks are called fissures and there
have been 10 fissures so far but all but
one of them have closed up so there's
only one that's still active so imagine
you take a hose a garden hose and you
puncture it ten times well it's gonna
shoot water out of those holes but now
imagine that same hose you pat you
puncture it just one time all that added
pressure but with one escape route goes
way into the air and because of that
that added pressure has shot the lava
three hundred and thirty feet in the air
now a similar eruption to this one
lasted eighty eight days back in 1955
there's no prediction for how long this
one's gonna last but it could very well
be a while so that's the latest guys
John let's go back to you well it's
fascinating Lonnie thank you
particularly the garden hose yeah good
really good description yes Gold Star
for analogies